the Kennedy Center held its 41st annual
celebration of the Arts last night the
Kennedy Center Honors this year's
honorees are jazz saxophonist Wayne
Shorter pop star Cher
country music legend Reba McEntire and
composer Philip Glass the creators of
the musical Hamilton also received a
special honor for their trailblazing
work join me in saluting our 2018
Kennedy Center honorees the Kennedy
Center Honors kicked off with a tribute
to the queen of country Reba McEntire
thank you so much for comforting me on
the phone through my tears Kelly
Clarkson gave a passionate performance
of Reba's iconic song fancy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
followed by tributes from Reba's country
music family
[Music]
also honored jazz saxophonist and
composer Wayne Shorter composer and
pianist Philip Glass is another of this
year's honorees always inviting us to
listen to something we've never heard
before
along with singer cher who was
introduced by Whoopi Goldberg I went
into your closet she is the true
original in a word she shared and
honored with performances of her hits by
Little Big Town Adam Lambert do you
and her longtime friend Cyndi Lauper
[Applause]
in a break with tradition the Kennedy
Center honored a contemporary work
recognizing the co-creators of the
musical Hamilton writer and actors
lin-manuel Miranda joined some of the
original Hamilton cast on stage for a
performance
they brought audience members to their
feet it was quite an evening
presidents often attend this event but
President Trump did not attend for the
second year in a row we should note that
you can watch the Kennedy Center Honors
on Wednesday December 26th right here on
CBS and I did go last night and it was
absolutely spectacular and you talked to
Reba McEntire well since coming you know
to all my friends in Texas who grew up
with me they knew I used to listen to
Reba all the times it was such a
pleasure to meet her in person she is
incredibly lovely and I know you spoke
with the cast of Hamilton well there
haven't yeah the collaborators about how
they did it all together which is an
amazing you know conversation about how
they work together